can we try it can we talk about your
Twitter and a bit we please follow me on
Twitter guys at the anime manic with the
wrong clip this is why can you please
explain your Twitter and okay
whenever I go on Twitter right I don't
follow hentai artists on Twitter because
I don't need to because this man's got
me cuz as you know on Twitter when you
when you like when you like a picture
there's a good chance for some reason
especially Joey's typically it comes on
my Twitter and I'm asked at at least
every time I open Twitter six or seven
like either like full-on sex things or
like very very lewd it's always Joey
it's like I'm like I don't follow porn
Oh like by Joey Bissinger and it's like
how did you get to this point he's what
I don't understand right like how many
people do you follow on Twitter like on
average 600 about about that okay right
you both follow about over 500 people
yeah and like this isn't just you to
like I've had this from like mutual
friends of mine everyone says you know
that my likes end up on everybody's
framework like a my own like Twitter
preferred like what I have no [ __ ]
clue per it is I'd say 70 to 80 percent
of the time I see loose on my timeline
it is you it is traitor [ __ ] first of
all you're welcome
okay because this used to be the case
and yeah I swear you're way more timid
about it how did how did it because I'm
scared of doing that cuz i I don't know
cuz I I mean I shouldn't really cuz I
wish you get half naked sin my videos
but yeah I don't know I was cause I was
worried about like she's just having
porn on my thing but now I guess I get
away with it cuz how did you go from not
sharing porn to basically just being be
the hentai I've I've always shared
that's the thing have you didn't I mean
maybe not as frequently no no now you're
seeking I I think it's it was just
Twitter changing the like button to be
basically the remark
what it is because is because for the
entirety that I've been on Twitter yeah
I've liked hentai yeah because I
followed hint I like people like hentai
outside like yeah I've discovered but
I've never retweeted it because of this
exact reason I don't want other people's
timelines but sweet o was just like hey
let's just like make the like button
like a raider retweet button i got us
how much of your feet is just head
that's why I asked I asked to see his
phone do you want to see you nail it
wasn't that bad when I first saw it
right the thing is I don't follow that
mini Han Toyotas yeah I know that's hard
to believe but I I genuinely don't the
thing is I follow a Han tae artist that
love retweeting other hand time yeah
yeah and that's where I find all the
people okay
scroll scroll through stream wait what
you scroll down my Twitter I'll see
let's see how many how many come up oh
that one one in three can you also like
everyone that appears likes from oh yeah
go to Ike's go to my life oh that's
another one that's two in a row oh wait
there's a Jimmy Neutron that that's not
meant I go that's basic okay let me
while they looking through this widow
let me defend myself real quick okay the
reason why I like it is because at the
end of the day these are just drawings
right there's a difference between
liking like actual human pawn versus
just a picture this man's about to go
the hens eyes are true I'm genuinely one
of those people who looks at hantai as
odd no I totally agree with you I'm
talking on behalf of every hand tire
lover watching this episode including
you
I can't I just I don't know if I look at
it and like just crack open a beer and
just enjoy anyway no no I've gone to
that point right I've gone to the point
you will see in my you see my [ __ ]
room you see my [ __ ] office which is
just like full of like anime thighs and
stuff like that because it's gone to the
point where sometimes you just see this
like drawing of a girl
or thigh or something and I just don't
even get horny anymore I'm just like I'm
just I'm just [ __ ] impressed about
how they make it look how good they make
it yeah that was me when I saw them le
owed us in seven days because they're
genuinely like some hentai artists that
I've seen and I know of where I'm just
like if you made an all-ages manga yeah
you would sell like crazy oh no people
have people and people have like look at
like Nana she who made um [ __ ] easier
than that of a song yeah I love everyone
everyone has seen this chick before
alright now that she was originally like
a hardcore loli hantai artist yeah and
he made a really [ __ ] successful
all-ages comedy manga which is hilarious
yeah and like and then and even if they
don't make only just stuff look at
artists like nepata who is like
genuinely an amazing artist yeah and
that's what I will like because you know
we've gotten to this point where hentai
has just become like haha anime boobs
hilarious and horny on me like it's all
just become like a joke thing yeah I
don't I don't I don't want but I'm sick
of those jokes I'm like I want to save
this table because I was i I already get
a whole episode I'm ready I have too
many things to say about hentai and anti
artists that I can't fit it all slow
like five minutes much like on this
episode if you want to hand my episode
cuz we're gonna do it either way we're
gonna do it and give these guys like
three sips of beer and they just start
talking about anti I don't know like
what I watch hentai it's like it's for a
service you know I guess I do it today
I do the deed right like I don't sit
there and like swirl my wine glass and
am i weird
am i okay I want an S is probably the
answer it's the way am i weird to be
like sometimes I kinda just want to
watch hand-tied just do it yes that's
yes
he's already going through that phase
right now that is I'm sure III don't I
hem tied to me hasn't got to that point
right dojinshi and manga there's there
is no part of me in a porn where like I
watch a porn lighter immediately skips
two minutes in you know you are the
degenerate ear [ __ ]
I've bought a lot of doujinshi from my
artists I like yeah I don't think I've
actually read like physical copies of
dope sheet and like jacked off to it I
know that's TMI I'm sorry yeah I will
recommend you some [ __ ] okay I do
come on Twitter like in like in like
four episodes I'll come back I'll
totally agree with everything these guys
say I just so like you'll like
progression from like oh what the [ __ ] -
like you know what I love this artist
because because it's if you've read
enough - gingy and if you've read enough
yet eh manga there are so many dodging
cheese that just have really really good
plots yeah and and Tiger it's it's this
sips beer I hire to agree I must say
it's gotten to this point where
sometimes you just want the series to be
adapted into of hentai just so you can
see it animated yeah and sometimes
you've read these series that just do
something new with porn or hand side
they just have never seen before and
you're like wow this is like awakening
something in me right now this is
amazing yeah okay no I've never heard
someone describe I've watched em tight
and it awakened something and however
you know I've read where like at first I
was like okay I dig this art and then I
see like the edgy scenes and I'm like
okay I'm digging this like you know me I
have like a quarter chomping but then as
the story continues I'm like you know
what the guys [ __ ] the HEC podcaster the
wrong boys question to you and question
to all of you watching why do you think
thigh thigh highs are sexy and if the
answer isn't anime an anime awakens your
love for thigh highs your [ __ ] lies
oh I did it did I mean it
let's be real Japanese girls don't have
five yeah yeah so like if you just think
if you follow how I just like
entry-level right in the world of the
Jin cheese in H manga okay
that's like southern or me [ __ ] we've
gotten to that point with by - or me as
[ __ ] maybe in future we can return to
this topic when I've you know done my
research come back